成員的社交關係就三類,那三類呢,偷擬油的,給你加油的,然後耗油的。
有如果能保清楚這個關係,你就知道該怎麼處理了。
首先我們說偷擬油的,這個在職場裡特別呈現,它就是通過PWN,然後便利你,然後它自己活得成就完。
有些時候,你看我們上班,工作人員說多忙,他也不忙,你就說說辛苦也不辛苦。
但是明天下來就特別特別的累,因為身體的原因,你休一晚上就好了。
但是有的時候,是那種能量,能量滴了以後你就起不來,所以這種偷擬油的人多了以後。
然後你會發現你的情緒就很不穩定,只能憤怒,好糾律啊,然後有的時候是驅骨啊,對吧?
甚至有時候會出現這種聲音反揚,比如說你的衛徒,或者是偷偷。
第二類的話,是跟你加油的,這類的人就是你和他相處的時候,你會覺得非常地舒服,你可以做自己。
而且就是哪怕你的能量很低,你和他接觸的一段時間以後,你會發現你的能力爆破,本來自己沒多好有了,他總是能跟你的油像你加油,對吧?
充滿了能量,甚至有些能量特別高的人,他甚至都不消耗的接觸,有些時候可能就一兩一花,一兩段文字就能讓你充滿了能量。
那麼還有一類的話,就是耗有的,他倒不是故意的,他不是故意的,但是他有些時候就會有一些副能量。或者經常有份量,然後會把你當作一個術動,因為好朋友嗎?
然後然後跟你說,跟你說,然後你接觸中的份量就多了以後,你會發現你特別累,你特別的辛苦。但是,有些時候又是朋友嘛,對吧?
然後你本來自己的油就不多,然後你把自己的油給他一半,你想我把油給你一半,然後你還跑了,我們就要打油門出去,走得在意味的,沒有為什麼手殺還打的,對吧?
就是那個油還不夠他的那個手殺的對抗,所以有些時候,他是綁右,對吧?但是,你要明白那是他自己的功課,所以各位把你的朋友收理一下,三類,一類是偷扭的,一類是跟你加油的,然後一類是好友的,如果是跟你加油的,一定要多來往,有些時候還要學會反腐,如果是好友的,你要選擇,
而性的來往,你要明白有些事情是他自己的功課,偷理有的,能夠交往,就不交往。